did you watch the digimon movie when you
were a kid yeah do you remember the
soundtrack for that yes they had [ __ ]
bare naked ladies
yeah yeah [ __ ] less than jake fat boy
slim
like what was this soundtrack it was
screaming 90s
like do you remember that scene with
all-star
[ __ ] all-star in it yeah i'm i'm
totally serious
we had smash mouth how did they get
these rights because it was back in it
it was like back in the day of like 90s
movies
sound it wasn't like they had a
completely different soundtrack from the
japanese
release yeah so when they when they like
dubbed it and westernized it they put
all these like
western bands i couldn't because i
watched the japanese movie first
obviously but then
i went to a friend's place and he only
had the dub for it yeah i was like i've
never seen the dub so i might as well
watch a dog and then when i heard smash
math i was like
you guys playing a prank did you overdub
this with shrek
i wanna now just watch this movie just
to experience
mouthwash smash mouth and fat boy slam
yeah dude hearing fat boy slim i was
like what was it
so surreal it was because i didn't
realize how special it was when i was
watching as a kid
but now growing up i think back and i
realized man this was a really
weird soundtrack kindergarten they've
got coke on the table
all right fat boy slim song was it ah
right here right now was it was that one
it was a weapon of choice i think it was
weapon
yeah she was a weapon of choice yeah
just hearing weapon of choice in a
digimon movie i was like
you're just hearing fat boy slaying like
takes me back 10 years [ __ ]
boy slim dude that boy seems [ __ ]
great from brighton by the way
as a born and bred by titanian yeah
from my home from my hometown
damn any famous people from where you're
from connor i think there was uh lost
prophets that band but then i think they
were like pedophiles so
we quickly uh quickly abandoned that one
there was a band called it's called lost
profits and i think they were like a
[ __ ] i don't know they were like kind
of like a knock off of uh
like some way i i think i remember lost
profits like
the rock band that like was like british
fallout boy sort of ish
oh like panic at the disco kind of vibe
a little more rocky i think but yeah oh
okay
yeah i was actually i was watching a new
anime recently have you guys heard of
the great pretender
it's i have heard of it yes song no no
no no no no no no no okay okay okay
there's there's an anime called the
great pretender [ __ ] i've only seen
the first three episodes
it's like a netflix exclusive anime but
it seems like
it's it's [ __ ] great it's i saw a
preview for that i want to watch that
it's it's a heist show
that sets in america okay yeah exactly
you're like
do you when you think of heist show and
anime i think of leap leap on the third
right yeah this i can't think of
many other heist shows but they actually
the ending for that song
is the great pretender by freddie
mercury oh
oh he was i remember watching it i was
like well who who is this this kind of
sounds like queen
and i thought i know he is the actual
great pretender by freddie mercury
i know right i know i i sometimes wonder
that because
there's there's a few anime series where
they've gotten western songs yeah right
like um
what's what's uh paradise paradise kiss
uh that france
had france
yeah that was [ __ ] surreal oh that
was such a good opening though holy [ __ ]
eating the east opening
as someone great show that was a great
show that was a really good show but the
opening to me i love everything stands
out the most
oh yeah probably one of my favorite
openings of all time you know
you know i mean you know we're in a good
mood when either gun or not i put that
on
karaoke we're just like oh let's go baby
it's such a good song no it's great
because these are like the songs i could
put on on karaoke and just pretend like
i can you know
yeah like when was the last time that an
anime had
like a western song in it like before
great pretender was it
was it ergo proxy it might have
i don't know if there's like i can't
think of my head like how many
um actual english songs because there's
there's been japanese songs
or there's been japanese bands that have
sunk english you know i mean
in terms of actual pure here is like a
western band
who who is just got a got a song in here
there's also that anime from like the
early 2000s i just remember that has
always been duran duran song as the
opening oh yeah that was what the [ __ ]
was that that was
that was that it was the camera one the
camera one yeah what the [ __ ] was it
yeah
it was girls on film by duran duran
[Laughter]
speed grappler speed graphics speed
graphic
duran duran and like serial experiments
lane as well had this ver that had this
like really weird unique british indie
bands
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
connor's just sitting here being like
what's what's going on i've watched like
half these shows and i'm like
oh yeah they did have that oh my god i
just forget
like how could you think because i
listen i'm like oh that's cool
i'm gonna keep forgetting home of my day